welcome back to a free podcast live
every Friday except when it's not Friday
it's not at 3:00 at twitch.tv 4/8
reproductions today's guest is the
biggest name in YouTube's tech reviews
with nearly 6 million subs he's the guy
I always go to when I want tech info
that's real weather smart phones cars
laptops cameras this guy covers it I
feel like I'm doing a copy / h-34 temper
self no he is the excellent and
wonderful Marquis they say right Marcus
Marcus I don't say my name much in the
actual videos right one usually knows it
but yeah Marquez Marquez Brownlee thank
you for joining us appreciate it thank
you it's 7 p.m. currently if we're gonna
watch it on YouTube so you came out here
at the end of a long day spend time with
us but I appreciate what do you been up
to today today and most of this week has
been we're shooting a video on Tesla
Model 3 so I see yeah so we had a lot of
game planning it takes a lot to shoot a
car video because the car you know the
car is driving but then you need a
person outside the car sharing the car
as its driving it's a whole thing
it takes a lot make it look natural yeah
and it's gonna take a lot more in that
ending process but I have faith in it
but that was a lot of today was like
getting like some filling shots of
things that I think will help it flow
well right up until the Sun was going
down and then just came over here was
that the purpose for you coming out to
LA that was the main yeah
the main reason for the trip well for
those who listen the podcast know that
I'm a little bit of a Elon Musk fanboy I
put his dick in my mouth regularly and I
see how deeper I can get it yeah are you
uh are you a fan boy I'd say I'm a Tesla
fanboy for sure not at you want fanboy
well I can't bet against Elon yeah I
mean I'm saying boy I guess cuz I I
follow most of what he does
I fought yeah well okay let me start
here what did you think of the model 3
okay so model I own a Model S so that's
my comparison point for a lot of stuff
very similar which is good because when
you're buying a car you want it to live
up to maybe a higher car on the same
year so it felt familiar it's pretty
quick it's electric it's got a front
still all the same stuff were used to
but there's definitely some weird quirks
that I'll talk about in that full video
but like I think the main thing people
are concerned about is the screen there
are zero buttons in the car the only one
that that is in the car is required by
law is the hazards button up in the
corner but if everything is just on this
one screen in the middle including your
speed your gear is really it's just it's
unusual it's a weird setup yeah but uh
they did that because it's it's
self-driving and eventually you won't
really have to worry about that too much
but when you're driving you kind of have
this trained glance down to the side of
like instead of looking right down at
the speed you look kind of to the side
at your speed it's a little different
you know I I have a Model S yeah and one
thing it's it is bleeding edge because
sometimes I love that car of most days
but sometimes I hate it like through
that day the screen wouldn't turn on
like it just I go in and it doesn't so
that's how that I've had to be like
really late to turn on but it's never
just not turned he could still drive
yeah I was able to drive I didn't know
that but like that concerns me even more
in the model 3 when they're like oh
they're gonna be a little too edgy and
put it all on a screen and then all of a
sudden when you're counting too much on
that screen what I mean it doesn't start
yeah yeah there's a lot of edge cases
where like you got to wonder like is it
failsafe is it kind of work if the
screen doesn't work right yeah well you
I remember you had a huge issue with
your got it
what happened probably a worse problem
oh wait almost made me not want to buy
it I was before you it was a huge life
decision buying a Tesla cos I mean it's
an expensive car right but for me it was
more as much I won't say more about as
much about supporting the mission
statement of supporting e.v.p.s right
but your video made me think twice about
it more than anything else tell tell the
audience what happened to you okay so it
was a essentially it all came down to
the power steering obviously power
steering is this mechanical loads flew
and McCann I don't know how to describe
it exactly but it helps you steer the
car based on the weight of it so you can
change the steering weight you can have
a sporty or comfort steering all that
stuff but when the power steering fails
it's extremely hard to turn the wheel
any direction because the car is super
heavy so what I had was I was driving I
went to go turn left across traffic and
midway through my turn as the wheels
turned like 45 degrees the power
steering cut that's and I was cutting
across traffic unable to move the car
Wow this happened once got it like I
like it snapped back into working again
I finished my drive pulled over you know
got it towed got it fixed they replaced
the entire steering rack I was like
alright that's definitely fixed for sure
then a couple hundred miles later it
happened again Wow and that's dangerous
that was dangerous and the second time I
think was more dangerous the first two
times were in the same ride where I like
I was making a left turn but it wasn't a
big deal if I couldn't the second time
was like two cars next to each other
both making the LAV right and I was the
inside car oh no and so when it failed
if that guy had also made the left I
would have just t-boned him but he went
straight yeah so that was like a I
immediately pulled over that's a red
flag obviously whenever you have the
same issue more than once they escalate
your issue to like definitely solve it
because three in New Jersey is lemon law
you can give the car back for free Oh
interesting
yeah so they flout an engineer from here
basically had him diagnose the problem
and they found a corrosive element in
the wiring between the power steering
rack and some other part of the car so
they flew someone to they flew someone
out yeah to to check out my car that
took a couple extra days the first time
it was like one day we replaced that
you're good this time it was like
alright we'll fly someone out a couple
days later they found out what was wrong
they flew out the parts they needed to
fix it it was a whole thing for maybe
like a week and a half that they gave me
a loaner p100 D during those days when I
didn't have my car which was pretty dope
a nice service yeah
they owe one hand it's nice service by
the other hand they could have
you better have it serviced yes so yeah
they fix that and they pretty much
guaranteed it will never fail in that
exact way again if it does it's a lemon
but they say so since then no issues are
you paranoid at all making those left
curse do you still think about those
left turns no dude I'm I don't want to
say reckless but I'm very confident yeah
that sounds like I don't have the P 100d
that once insane but we both drove it
I've driven it because that we tested
and they gave us a loaner p100 ooh and
so in the few 100 d which is the highest
level model and the only difference
between the P 100 D and the step-down
which is like the 90 D or I guess it's
the one Hyundai now we got our we're
straight I can i've memorize the line
but at any rate the only difference is
the acceleration for example the one
below it goes 0 to 60 and 4.3 seconds
right or 4.2 I think now the p100 d does
it and 2.4 yeah it's a significant now
when I got that loaner car I put it in
ludicrous mode you have to be that's
like a contract saying that ok now when
you click this button and you and your
crash fatally you click the button just
let the world know you decided to do
this yeah it's it's ungodly and when I
it when I drove it my first thought was
like this is not safe this is not safe
at all yeah it's when you have that kind
of acceleration as personally not just 0
to 60 but like 30 to 80 right or like
for me it's all about the 0 to 30 in the
Tesla yeah I mean from zero the only
weird stuff you're doing is like at
stoplights or maybe someone pulls up
next to you and like wants to race which
doesn't really ever happen but like
you're on the highway and someone's you
know there's a gap and you need to get
to the exit do you slow it down and go
behind him or do you accelerate and go
in front of that car you see nine times
out of 99 you're going up and taking the
Front's it actually feels much safer cuz
we also have a Prius which was our
previous car yeah
and I still drive that one sometimes and
I feel less safe it's strange but I I
feel like I have more control over the
car that's what it comes down to so
technically and also this this has
happened before the car will if it sees
an impending collision right will try to
avoid it
someone soars into your lane it'll
swerve a little bit away I have an
experience and if it sees someone coming
up behind you about to rear-end you
really by itself it'll just kind of Juke
you forward a little bit that is to
avoid it and that's that's happened to
me in my car and that's definitely it
gave you a little boost yeah I thought
it was broken
now we're gonna round the same time and
it jeopardized your ass exactly it's a
wash exactly so tell me um you said you
were in the model three and it's a lot
like the Model S in your opinion do you
think the model 3 is a Model S killer
because the price is like the price is a
huge difference he's so like 40,000
bucks I think the fact the price
difference is so big is actually what
keeps it from being a Model S killer I
think there's gonna be people who are in
the market for a fifty sixty to seventy
thousand dollar car that aren't gonna
pick model three because of lower price
there and they want premium R and Model
S is always gonna be that I think it's
getting a refresh remembered in the next
year or two to update it with a lot of
the things that model three is currently
better at but I think because the price
difference is so big people who were
waiting to buy a Tesla until it was 35
grand are now gonna buy that not a model
so you think just the status symbol
alone is enough to to keep it alive yeah
I think it's just gonna basically having
at that lower price it's just gonna open
doors for way more people to buy it well
I hope that they do distinguish the
difference because yeah they try they're
pretty clear in their messaging I think
internally they have a lot of they're
trying to make sure people know Model S
is still the better car yeah doesn't say
yeah that there there's features and
things you I mean there's two two
screens instead of one like if you look
at model three oh this is the future
just one screen but like roadster is
gonna have to like their their higher
end stuff is still gonna have two
machines and two because they can afford
it I think they wanted they may have
wanted to do a heads-up display
like you know maybe having the the speed
on the like the windshield or something
like that all kinds of interesting
things that they couldn't do because of
the lower price right that they do in
the Model S right do you think that
Tesla is will be able to achieve all of
its goals I mean the the goals of the
company is is huge
and there's a lot of doubters and
naysayers of what Tesla is doing and and
to be frank they haven't been off to a
great start with their Model 3 launch
yet what they ended up making like 4,000
when they had promised to make like
50,000 they're way way way way behind do
you see them succeeding and what they're
setting out to do I I'm always hesitant
about the timelines they give sure
because they're Elon and that whole crew
is always super ambitious about like
yeah we'll do this and this year and
like the Roadster is the same thing 2020
yeah right like that's gonna be at least
a couple years after that I think but I
think the actual goals are setting
they're eventually hitting them when
people are saying like they're weren't
gonna hit him at all yeah so stuff like
production of Model S which has been
ramping up kind of the same way like
model threes at the beginning of that
climb sure and they kind of mapped out
that climb with Model S and I think they
sold their two hundred thousandth Model
S last year which people never thought
they would defer so you know it might
not be the same people call it Elon time
right yeah as literally it goes all the
way down to like the time of the event
like he'll kill get on stage of five
o'clock and they it's 503 and we're like
yeah maybe so timelines not so much but
I think they eventually they'll get
there yeah interesting I hope so
I think there's so much demand for the
Model 3 a fully electric it's a great
great car and the 100 something thousand
orders already four hundred actually
sell it I feel like the demand is
infinite if he can actually meet the
production yeah before other companies
do because everybody's he kind of opened
the floodgates in terms of it's a weird
thing I
I've been looking more into car stuff
since I started doing these car videos
and like other companies are like
thinking about getting into electric and
they're like promising they're gonna do
it sometime right but I don't see it yet
and that's weird to me that these like
hundred-year-old companies
I mean I guess they're just kind of a
huge yes and they can't be as agile yeah
they're behind it's it's insane say what
you will about Yonkers there's a lot of
people that dislike him and I think it's
just a lot of contrarians who are like
all these people loved him so I'm gonna
hate him that's a whole nother thing
[ __ ] those people but seriously I don't
like what the hell was I saying
say what you will about you learn but
that guy is so infinitely far ahead of
the game like legit paradigm shift so in
the automotive field yeah the
infrastructure I think they're onto
something there obviously the whole
electric car thing they're stupid far
ahead on like right even if like Porsche
tomorrow came out with a $70,000
electric car that does everything Model
S does they don't have the super
charging that they don't have you know
the the autonomous driving they don't
have like seven or eight also massive
projects right that this one car does so
like yeah they're really far ahead it's
unbelievable I mean it's unbelievable
and like like you said at the beginning
everyone thought it was a fantasy and a
joke and it wasn't reasonable but now if
you when you drive around LA I don't
know what it's like Jersey but like
Tesla's are dime-a-dozen here yes so I
noticed that I noticed that about 3 out
of every 10 cars is a Prius yes yeah and
then one out of every 10 is a Model S
and the new everything else in New
Jersey still a lot of Prius is not a lot
of Tesla's but you still kind of start
to see him more mm-hmm my car was the
first the first P 100 D on the East
Coast accordant but yeah you see a Model
S or Model X once in a while but it
still isn't common on the East Coast and
the same thing with supercharger here
it's great thing there's just in
California in LA it's like a combination
of a lot of wealth with people who are
environmentally conscious I think that's
what I noticed also about shooting Model
Model 3 now model 3 is that Unicorn that
people haven't seen on the road
first I hadn't ever seen one what I saw
it at the event but I hadn't seen one on
the road since then when I got here
walking from the hotel to in-and-out I
saw the first one that I ever saw on the
road and then so like you know we got
the car and we're driving it around and
like you're at a supercharged it's like
there's like Tesla enthusiasts just kind
of like around and all their heads are
just kind of like yo what is is that the
model 3 yeah I weren't sure that is
that's the one like we want to know like
what's the price of it what are the
options on it like all the questions
come out as they'd heard about it but
they hadn't seen it you know who got him
all three Jake right he must have been
super early
yeah like day of order maybe did you
order a model 3 I didn't hmm I I would
love to but I think I'm just with ya if
I ever have two cars it would be
roadster a Model S I think so that's
another thing I want to say you so Tesla
came out with another car that you can
pre-order yeah the Roadster so that's P
100 D isn't unsafe enough they're like
here's a car that's even better at yeah
possibly killing yourself yep which is
the Roadster and and it takes a $50,000
deposit right which you which I you have
to pick to EWTN's curve yes and boy yeah
man
so the specs like again that's like a
it's more of a projection than an actual
product at the store it doesn't exist
yeah like they drive the one on stage
but that's not like the finished product
yeah but they gave numbers like oh yeah
it'll go 250 miles an hour and it'll do
0 to 60 in 1.9 seconds
two hundred kilowatt hour battery but
like none of that is physically possible
yeah nine that's gotta be one of the
fastest cars on the road I mean what's
better than that that would be the
fastest production car ever by like 20%
if you do get that car please drive very
safely because that is yes that is very
dangerous that is not so I have a lot of
I'll definitely do a video if it's just
like a bring all I'll have you guys like
sit in the passenger seat and like I
think that's gonna be hilarious but uh
yeah I'm
have to holster some some crazy moves
you really didn't that car is gonna be
sick what's the price tag on in the mold
price tag so there's the the base the
base model why even have a baseball at
that point the weird thing is the base
model does 0-60 in 1.9 and he didn't say
what the optioned up version will them
options just like a static just put
swings right on the side just flies over
traffic yeah it's so that yeah it's
50/50 grand deposit and then 150 grand
at the delivery for the base model and
then there's the founders it probably
sounds weird to say this but that seems
like a reasonable price for what you get
uh yeah when you compare it on paper to
other stories that everyone else oh well
it merely keeps up with a Bugatti but a
Bugatti is two million dollars for
Bugatti about it the fastest 0-60 that
was pretty soft
um the fastest here is six is if you
look it up on Wikipedia it's like the
Porsche 918 spyder the laferrari at the
Bugatti all those cars are 1.8 million
dollars plus right so you dollar car so
if you're competing that's the end
that's the thing is like people will
compare it against that like well you
know it'll catch it in like the quarter
mile sure well no this one holds it up
in a point eight seconds like oh well at
least you have a trunk in this one well
this one also has a trunk like every
time you try to compare it to the best
car and some other let's see if we can
do it I'm excited I'm it's not
everything they showed on stage is still
great it's alright it's about time for
our first commercial break guys we have
got so much more jerking off to do about
Elon Musk you won't want to miss it
and other stuff obviously too but mostly
you love musk so guys please don't go
away we'll be back shortly thank you
guys thank you to me Indies for
sponsoring this episode every podcast
you want to look good with your
significant other this Valentine's Day
and you don't want to just give them
another box of chocolates because
frankly you're not gonna get any most
likely oh here's a box of chocolates I'm
just another guy please you got to match
to get some right EULA yep
you got a match to get some that's the
slogan of me undies check it out this is
a really cool thing that they're doing
get a matching pair of unique fun and
powerful undies perfect balance of
comfortable fit and exciting prints do
not spend another valence today given
the same old gift go to Mandy's comm
slash h3 to find the best match for your
match like your match I do really love
their Valentine's Day it's beautiful
commemorate your love you know here's
the deal this undies are so soft and
luxurious you're gonna be wondering what
is are these drabs what is this garbage
that I've been draping under over my
junk because it's just you deserve
better you know they're the most
comfortable we're talking three times
softer than cotton try to fathom that if
you can or just buy a pair and you can
feel it for yourself so this Valentine's
Day get your partner gift that's fun for
the both of you order by February 5th at
10 a.m. for free standard shipping so
your gift arrives on time matching pairs
are fun thoughtful comfortable and you
can share it with your significant other
here's the deal
100% satisfaction guarantee me and Eve
guarantee me undies guarantees you and
your significant other will love your
matching pair or your money back you
have got nothing to lose if you don't
love it three times softer the cotton
Wow
your minds not blown send it back it's
that easy you got nothing to lose so
right now head on over to me and ease
calm slash h3 and for our listeners when
you purchase menus for the first time
you get 20% off and free shipping free
shipping yo yeah my favorite song
yeah you don't have to spend $100 on
like Jake Palmer once again they're so
convinced you're gonna love this
underwear you got a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed so yeah listen
if you don't love your first pair get oh
god dang refund so there's a no-brainer
get 20
percent off matching undies for you and
your significant other hundred percent
there's a lot of percentage here 20
percent off 100% satisfaction guaranteed
are you waiting for order it by February
5th for free standard shipping and to
get it in time yes so to get 20% off and
free shipping on hunter percent
guarantee satisfaction go to me Indies
comm /h 3 that's me undies that gab
/h 3 and this will be the best
Valentine's gift that you will ever give
and if nobody if somebody doesn't touch
your penis as a result I can't guarantee
they'll give you your money back but
you're free to ask there's a chance
there's always a chance thank you to me
undies hellofresh thank you for
sponsoring our program we have teamed up
with hello fresh and we are offering
everyone in our audience
$30 off your first week of deliveries
when you go to hell of fresh calm and
use the offer code h 3 podcast that's
one word HD podcasts hellofresh what is
it just the greatest most convenient
revolution in groceries Oh
shredders tearing up the paper it let me
clear my throat here shredder is being a
shredder he we don't we Hughes have a
shredder like a paper shredder now we
just throw it on the floor
he takes it of everything he has our
social security numbers and all that but
I trust him listen here's the deal with
hellofresh convenient fun a total blast
flexible they send you groceries
everything you need measured perfectly
out in little patches with instructions
nutritional information for example they
were like hey how about a little chicken
scallopini as an example so they send
you the chicken fresh beautiful chicken
they send you all the ingredients all
the sauce everything you need to cook a
master meal something that you knowing
you probably would never cook because
let's face it we're pizza guys us boys
out here and it's always pretty easy to
cook meals yeah so you don't need to
cook for like hours I'm telling you
Valentine's Day you put on some you make
a little hello fresh somebody is gonna
touch you in your special place
at least a touch one of these for sure
can I get one of these from you this
Valentine's Day EULA one of these in
pens if i play my cards right
choose a delivery day that works for you
pause for weeks when you're out of town
everything comes free and measured and
labeled here's the deal Ali the hello
fresh has a wide variety of chef's
curated recipes that change weekly
there's three plans to choose from
classic veggie and family you could
choose between meat fish and seasonal
produce vegetarian recipes with
plant-based protein grains and seasonal
produce the whole freakin family is
gonna love them or if you're single and
you know you can also cook it for
yourself this Valentine's Day and cry
over your chicken it's a good seasoning
salt you know you don't need salt you
can season it with your own tears but
you'll love it anyway it's organic as
Heelys pointed out I've had a ton of fun
cooking with hellofresh
it's just it's a total blast you don't
have to go to the grocery store you
don't have to go online and find recipes
you you're not gonna mess it up because
they make it so hard to mess up and it's
always delicious fun easy to clean up
it's a total blast so they make in
cooking easy delicious it's a balanced
meal and it's less than ten dollars a
meal okay Capisce feel confident with
the simple recipes outline on picture
step by step go to hello fresh calm and
use the code h3 podcast to get $30 off
your first weeks deliveries my friends
very nice one more time go to hello
fresh the link is in description receive
$30 off your first order with promo code
h3 podcast thank you my friends to these
sponsors if you're in the market for a
little nice meal or some undies please
consider supporting our sponsors thank
you guys and we're back
welcome back everybody they Street
podcasts thank you for sticking around
if you guys have any questions please
give us a ring at eight one eight two
one four eight 504 maybe we'll air your
question if you can get past the Great
Firewall known as Ian the intern he's a
hater so watch out give him a piece of
your mind I shouldn't say that people
just been [ __ ] with them I'm kid
that's true me
come on give the guy a break he's got a
tough job um I wanted to ask you how's
our set up here I was thinking maybe you
could critique it at being a camera
expert and a mic expert what's going on
here so it's pretty solid
pretty good I'm impressed we mess with
you know video sets all the time there's
there's a nice color variety there's
lights everywhere which is good I like
this purple light behind the superficial
sign here thank you cuz like colored
lights what is that a Philips hue
lightstrip like those types of things
nice touch Oh weird yeah I think what's
what helps a lot is how many sound
dampening materials you can sneak in a
place like the couch sure yeah the foam
everything yeah a curtain the curtain
you know what's interesting I don't know
if you guys can see this uh Sarah if you
slow him back here but behind here
there's a window oh yeah to the street
do like a Main Street there's like
there's like foam like this thick Ben
and it actually blocks the sound out
quick yeah I'm I would never have
guessed that mm sometimes I forget that
there was a way if you want it to open
it would you have to rip all the foam
down good like you can make an incision
slide well I wouldn't do that not
missing much for that window um I wanted
to ask you
that's have you heard the rumor that an
apple is gonna buy Tesla no dad did you
pull that out of your ass dan told me
that he's like did you hear the rumor it
is that a real thing are you showing me
no that was a real thing so there's and
as when I read it I read the article I
knew it would probably make you rage so
forward there's legit
rumors about Apple trying to make a car
which is far-fetched by itself but apple
also has billions and billions and
billions of dollars of cash so on
roasters worth of money yeah I mean they
could just by Ford and just make cars
with them that's what I've seen they
wouldn't they're super stingy but I feel
like Tesla's position so damn well that
I could see that it makes sense but also
like why Ellen would never do that right
that's what I thought but he's kind of
at the helm of the ship I think they
just announced like a 10-year plan for
his salary to inflate as he stays with
them like I he's pretty locked in there
I was I wanted that to tell you about
that or ask you about that because they
just announced Tesla Ellen's pay package
and it's set up so that if he doesn't
perform well he gets nothing and he has
milestones for every 50 billion that he
increases the company's worth for
reference the company is currently worth
559 bill yeah fifty nine billion okay so
the milestones go all the way up to six
hundred and fifty billions which is like
Ludacris right I'll make it one of the
top five most valued companies in
America yeah but if he somehow reaches
that goal he will be the richest man in
the world something worth like two
hundred billion but I mean you know it's
a fairy tale yeah I mean it's a good
incentive it's a good no I wouldn't mind
that that's sort of a all right if you
get if you get seven million subs you
get a billion dollars all right come on
I might if I was gonna be like I'm on it
I got I'm working on it click oh baby
yeah one thing I did for sure here was
Apple buying Netflix oh no I mean it was
there was articles about it Dan didn't
just make it up but it's also articles
the body of being a rumor yeah well and
I still hasn't happened yet so it hasn't
happened yeah it was word article some
like high-level forecaster said there's
a 40% chance Wow of Apple buying Netflix
what you guys hear that when I hear that
I think that's the highest number you
can give without sounding like you're
guessing because if they
like well what is it yeah but if you go
over 50 and it doesn't happen you look
dumb so he's like yes afford ears that's
smart you could say of anything really
new 40 40 percent chance I'm not
actually sitting here right now but it's
only 40 so what how do you feel about
Apple owning Netflix though so on the
surface I get it
content you get a lot of like content
leather licensing obviously Google and
YouTube is sort of a giant that you have
to compete with somehow and the only way
Apple's tried original content on their
own and that's alright but like Netflix
yeah why not just start there so I get
it
but as a direct I guess do you think
that it would affect what they do this
everywhere loves Netflix and I think
like even people are fans of Apple kind
of hate Apple right a little bit is that
a true is that accuracy a man I really
don't like Apple there's a hmm yeah
there's a bit of a trapped element to it
I think sometimes if you ask people why
they use an iPhone they're like well my
message
the blue bubbles that I met have you
heard the walled garden analogy no it's
kind of people describe the Apple
ecosystem as sort of like a walled
garden where it's really nice and pretty
on the inside and all your friends are
in there but if you ever get a peek over
the top of that really high wall you see
like all the meadows and things that are
outside but like climbing that wall and
leaving iMessage and all my friends are
in here and why don't I just down here
sounds like a click yeah what do you
think about Apple as a company do you
consider them still to be like tech
industry leaders or are they I get the
sense personally that there's starting
to become a little obsolete a little bit
dated and they're losing their edge
every time I think that I look at their
bank account yeah but they made that
money a while ago yeah but it's like
they they're I think I saw an article
and I might be quoting it wrong but like
the iPhone 10 was like the first iPhone
to not increase the rate of breaking the
second record sales like so they really
measure
iPhones of like it broke their sales
record of course by how much by more
than last okay they're still doing well
when it breaks the sales record by not
as much as they broke the last sales
record then it's like his Apple doomed
so the ex were not bad they just weren't
didn't shattered all the way it did
shatter all the records but not by much
are you serious so it did outperform all
their previous fall but I think this
year so this year there were three
phones so I don't know if the ten
individually outsold the all the rest
but like
year after year like the iPhone is the
most sold phone by volume was it so
multiple yeah what the [ __ ] if you just
look at I phone it's funny we iPhone
when you listen to like tech radio and
stuff like that it's always like the
iPhone X is at colossal failure yeah I
always I was gonna ask you why was the
iPhone at such a failure so it's a I
mean yeah I wouldn't say it's a failure
by anyone's standards other than people
who didn't buy it who thought they were
like there's people who were like I'm
gonna wait for the latest iPhone and
then the new iPhone comes out and they
buy it and then a year later they say
I'm gonna wait for the next iPhone and
then it comes out and they buy it and
then this year they said I'm gonna buy
the iPhone 10th and then it came out and
it was $1000 and they were like that
price then maybe not maybe what was it
previously like 800 usually around 800
till that thousand price tag gets a
little scary I mean it's a starting
price like you could option up previous
year's iPhones to be like 979 just if
you put more storage in it an option got
the you know the gold or whatever but
this year it's like all right starting
at $9.99 mm-hmm one more storage is it
1250 now like bro their margins are
probably so insane on those phone
definitely they're making their money
but like what do you what do you think
if you had to guess what it cost to make
one of those phones actually that's out
there I fix it does tear downs I think
the number is a couple hundred but it's
definitely not more than five hundred
bucks to make an iPhone 10 if it costs
500 that would be I would a reasonable
margin I want to say I don't know why
170 is in my head but I feel like it's
less than 200 bucks to make it I feel
like so to five times margin at that
price point is pretty nuts
that is kind of what margins are no yeah
but when you're selling like a high-end
item
that's that expensive because you got us
you still have to sell it I mean a
thousand dollars is a big barrier to
cross for most people right but they do
it that's all about that I but where
else are you gonna get it
we're also gonna get Oh Dan is saying
it's three seventy three seventy two to
make no come from Dan
I know there's tear downs 370 that's on
uh time I just googled it mmm
interesting wait so I mean that okay
it's reasonable
yeah it's really I think it is actually
Matt if I if I build anything and I cost
me if you're into seventy bucks to make
and I looked as sweet as an iPhone 10
how much what I sell it for huh yeah I'm
not good because the cost doesn't end
there
you know development there's a lot of
cost being all those billboards all the
advertisement that's not a joke
billions in advertising man they're
likes apples like smog from The Hobbit
they have a really interesting
advertising strategy they you might have
noticed they never use social media hmm
they didn't have a Twitter until this
year and even now they never use it they
don't have an official Facebook page I
don't think they don't use myspace I
wonderfully because they think of all
those people as their competitors in a
weird way yeah its its brand image on
one hand like the if you can't control
the public image of your brand then why
be on that platform
they you know they upload their ads to
YouTube disable ratings disable comments
just leave it really chamber you can't
you can't like [ __ ] the image garden
wall exactly if you if because I'm sure
if you saw like if you subscribe to
Apple on YouTube and you saw the video
right as they uploaded it and there was
like comments and ratings and be like I
don't think I like this I just like it
that would be a failure for them so they
won't allow that to happen interesting
but they have plenty of billboards
newspaper ads because there's no
interaction there yeah you don't have
some some twelve-year-old screaming
about you can carefully curate where
exactly that shows up that's so
interesting I didn't know that about
them yeah that kind of solidifies the
cult theory even more mm-hmm they
definitely carefully control the way
people see apples company um here's a
little 180 for you
what's your opinion about the growing
discussion of AI mm-hmm
Elon Musk our boy for example is pretty
alarmist about it I've talked about this
on the show quite a bit right but he
comes out with statements to scare the
[ __ ] out of me
saying he's like we need to regulate it
this shit's gonna wipe us off the planet
you're not taking this threat seriously
and then there's a lot of other people
on the other end who are experts and who
you know come from a place of authority
who think that it's complete
overreaction they don't see it as a
threat what are your thoughts on the
danger and potential of a is that
something you thought about yeah a
little bit I tend to separate the the
two different like it's like a Venn
diagram of two different terms which are
AI artificial intelligence and machine
learning so if you talk to Google or
anyone who's trying to do better things
with software with the same hardware
they think machine learning is the best
it's it's the greatest because they can
make software smarter it can recognize
more things it can train to get better
stuff like your Google home or Alexa or
whatever you use will get better with
that but then there's artificial
intelligence as like an entire other
blob which is like you know does it
start to make decisions for itself does
it is it aware of itself
I guess it's out of the point right
that's selling word motives yeah that
that whole question so I am all for
machine learning and and that's been
actually really exciting the last like
two or three years but artificial
intelligence is kind of a giant question
mark for me not much opinions about it
not really I because I don't have much
hands-on experience with it like if I
had like a robot that I could talk to
and like asking questions and really see
how I feel about it maybe I would have a
stronger opinion but as of right now
robots are all at these pretty corny
like barely functional you know humanoid
type things that are purpose-built or
sure maybe clean your house so like yeah
yeah well it's it's the time old
philosophical question you know it's
it's not a new question but it seems
like increasingly that it seems like
maybe you Han thinks so far into the
future that he's thinking like well in
2030 when yeah this technology is so far
ahead like what are we gonna do about
robots that don't like us right I mean
like
I think it's falling to just dismiss
what he's saying mm-hmm got to hear the
guy out well yeah it also seems a little
far-fetched that there's this like
dystopian like matrix future that's been
in sci-fi for like centuries you know
would actually come to fruition yeah
it's just weird coming from Elon I go
for it yeah exactly that makes it like
if someone else said this I'd be like
yeah come on let's be real
yeah the only thing I feel like being on
YouTube and dealing with YouTube's
algorithm kind of makes me feel like
it's not that far because YouTube's
algorithm is already like cold
calculating they are yeah that's a
little bit of both to that's because the
machine learning is like there's
programmers that are telling it like
they they're trying to train it to do
certain things better so they get
feedback from us and you know you need
to better recognize the difference
between iPhone 10 and iPhone xxx like
one thing's cool one thing's not like
being able to take that new information
and and adjust all the things that's
doing hopefully works well with machine
learning but like with artificial
intelligence I don't know it's like this
whole other question most definitely
yeah one of our best theories is that
the singularity already happened and
Elon is an agent of the AI oh yeah that
is the puppet master of everything
happening in the world working to its
benefit chew on that my dude my god Elon
what is a [ __ ] undercover agent for
the AI single a little bit terrified now
I'm saying man
what are you fine knows that video like
this is just someone sends a T or it
just kind of comes out where I did we
find out I found that one it was kind of
they just float around you know I'm open
to the world I think I must have seen it
on cringe maybe or I guess catch a lot
of them on reddit
sometimes people email at me [ __ ] and
I'll catch it on their subreddit I catch
it but every once in a while you find a
video like that and a rabbit hole and
get about yeah I can't part on this one
yeah
Carly's ledge instant ledge do you have
any predictions for future tech anything
we may not expect that you think we'll
have a really huge impact on our society
like maybe something that's coming up
that people are not realizing how
important it is right
that's like the golden question and I
wish I had a great answer Maureen but I
don't and I and even like like family
members will ask me like so what's the
next big thing I'm like is the next
phone that comes out like it seems like
we're on this sort of a railroad track
where we kind of know what's next over
and over and over again and eventually
we get there down that that railroad but
for now it's a lot of incremental like
slightly faster chips slightly better
banner with slightly more memory
slightly better cameras and over over
time it all gets better as a whole do
you think that there's a narrative some
kind of disrupter where all the sudden
it's like oh the internet or I know what
I'm sorting it is what I'm hoping it's
battery technology doctor please battery
technology for so long and things about
like graphene batteries or whatever but
like at the end of the day my phone
lasted for one day like five years ago
why is it still only last for one day
what is the power consumption is going
up like is the same an energy density
gets a little bit better but like our
phones are so much more powerful and do
so many more things this huge screen you
saw we had Nokia's that played snake
exactly so like it makes sense that my
phone still only lasts a day but I'm
looking forward to like a like a
multiplier type of breakthrough where
like now our phones last a month that
gets better and it lasts like a year
like that type of thing that would be
awesome but also just me do see the
video where a guy bit a battery in a
store and it just exploded why why I
don't wasn't know why he bit it what he
just gave it a little nibble say it's
like a security like a CCTV camera in a
store somewhere and you
all that up you guys this is very
graphic should I know not know it's like
a like a totally watchable video but
it's just like a you see this thing
burst into flames if you puncture a
battery it will explode like the energy
density is super high like if you take a
knife to the phone in your pocket it
will be very dangerous because of all
fuels and bullets that actually happen
with what the Samsung right last year
where people's phones are just exploding
yeah so that was a we that was an
extremely small thing like they tried to
push the battery up into the corners of
that phone so much that what happened
was like they were layering essentially
folding layers of the battery in there
and some of them the layers just caught
and touched in the wrong place
Wow and that was enough for the phone
blow to close to the Sun exactly oh so
they had to you know put slightly less
dense batteries in and slightly smaller
and that worked out but like batteries
are already super dense I just wish
there was like some milk yeah it's not I
don't want to like get into trouble with
YouTube or twitch it's just a little gay
like why did he yeah where the flip is
it here it is let's pull it up it's in
China so does that help explain test oh
yeah what was he testing what happens
when you buy the battery all right let's
see oh wow
like did he not think like maybe uh oh
man that's pretty easy that is intense
but woah that I'm happy to say that they
all seemed okay yeah they all seemed
relatively okay why are you biting at
you exactly that's probably the girl
right there is like she got the it's in
a public store wait I know people are in
your mouth you're not in the lab she's
China's a weird place because like
people just put batteries in their
mouths there or like they don't
understand like how stoplights work and
people are starting to drive for the
first time like Chinese villages that
were all the sudden getting tons of
money for some reason and they're just
like running people over there off the
grid now they're on know what to do it's
insane
well here's a fog about predictions for
future tech VR a lot of people have a
lot of money and investments big
companies big people big names putting
their chips and their money into
developing VR you think that this has as
much potential as a lot of people seem
to think it has long term yes short term
now I'm a short term pessimist about VR
and I don't know if it's because like
I've tried to make 360 videos and they
all sucked or if it's like every time I
scroll past one on Facebook I scroll
extra fast cuz it's so dumb but like
eventually I think because as tech gets
better we'll be able to make better VR
because VR there's there's also VR and
AR so like a are you kind of have this
augmented element to whatever world
you're in maybe it overlays something
somewhere but VR you need your entire
world to be built for you
so whether it's a roller coaster you're
writing or a map you're playing a game
in someone built all of that so better
VR happens after we get better maps and
better environments to play in and and
more and more painstakingly detailed
things and then the resolution of the
headsets we're playing in gets better
and you can see these things better all
of that has to get better before VR is
even a little bit interesting to me as
far as like you know everyday
application because right now it's just
like gaming I actually tend to agree
back in like the 90s ever it's that's
when it started in like VR yeah and I
remember when I was a kid I went to a
mall I must have been 10 years old they
had this massive platform and I put on
all this gadgets and it was like 50
pounds on me it was a whole experience
now we have the technology where you
could put the vibe on and it's really
fun it's really cool experience but you
still have a wire and the games aren't
great and I don't know it just you still
have this giant goggle in your head the
latest thing that I saw was at CES this
year they had did you OCS know they had
a wireless adapter for those I saw that
video and crap so so at least you don't
have wires you still have one wire to a
battery in your pocket but at least you
don't trip over the hair and huge
difference the immersion yeah so am
yeah that's that that'll take some work
but like you still have to build the
entire environment that you're in so
you're saying it takes a lot more work
to make a great VR game yeah because you
have three dimensions instead of two a
lot yeah interesting so yeah I mean that
takes time but I'm ready I'll get better
- cool obviously when you get to the
point where like you just are in your
own mind that's kind of when where we
are will will take over will be like
that scene in uh what's that movie where
they're just kind of sitting back Polly
it's wall-e there's a scene in wall-e
where the guys just in the chair the
fatties on the screen just in his face
yes dad [ __ ] I need to be doing yeah
okay let's take another break we will be
back so much to talk about you guys you
do not want to go away we'll be back
shortly
thanks guys see you soon thank you to
audible for sponsoring this episode of
the h3 podcast audible is offering our
audience a 30 day free trial
how about that unbelievable if you want
to listen to it audible has it just go
to audible.com slash h3 podcast or this
is some high-tech new stuff text h3
podcasts to the number 500 - 500 Wow the
future the future is now soon you just
have to think just think h3 podcasts for
a free audiobook I love I absolutely
love Ottawa they've got an incredible
service they've got an incredible
catalog of audiobooks this could change
everything you do because you're going
to be entertained you can be educated
whatever is you need you're gonna have
some laughs whatever it is you're doing
you're playing video games you're
cooking you're exercising or maybe you
just are don't want to listen to your
teacher drone on cuz school sucks am i
right
no kids rule right you know wow dude it
what knowledge is power it's alright
knowledge is power
I'm not knowledge is power guys go to uh
audible.com slash h3
guest so I've been reading or have been
listening to how to win friends and
influence people now this book it sounds
corny okay it was written in like the
30s this is an old time-tested book how
to win friends and influence people when
I was in a rut recently and I was really
sorry I once I was in a rut recently and
this book really got me in a fresh
perspective it see it some of the stuff
is obvious but it really got me thinking
about my interaction of people in a
different way I can't recommend this
book enough if you're no matter who you
are that's gonna help you live happier
interact with people happier the thesis
of the book is like we all learn about
math and history and science but we
don't ever learn about human relations
yeah social interactions and that's kind
of the most impactful meaningful thing
in all of our lives is how we interact
with the people around us right how to
win friends and influence people well
change your life if you're ready to
receive the message of it and it's
written in a way that's easily digested
it's a ton of fun I can't recommend it
highly enough my friends so here is what
I'm proposing to you okay go to
audible.com slash h3 podcast or text a
true podcast - 500 - 500 and get a 30
day free trial listen to this book and
it's great you got nothing to lose free
trial like that's a UD IB le dot-com
slash a street podcast or text a street
podcast - 500 - 500 you get to keep
these books no matter what so even if
you can't you membership you get to keep
it and they can never take that away
from you and you can also share a book
from your library with anyone if it's
their first time accepting a book
through this feature so you if it has a
big impact on you you get it for free
you share it with the front it's a
beautiful thing guys so thank you to all
those supporting us one more time that's
a eud ible calm / h3 pockets audible.com
slash a street podcast thank you so much
for support
us and next up we've got the great and
wonderful man crates Oh a bird I'm not
kidding anyway any man any man of the
male gender whether he's a lumberjack or
a whatsit really a masculine thing I
don't know me and janitor me you're
gonna love what man crate has to offer
it's Valentine's Day
till lady's listening and instead of
giving a guy a box of chocolates for
Dante which is so boring
surprise him with a heart-shaped box of
delicious boobs okay
brookies yeah introducing man Chris calm
the only place to find awesome gifts
that guys love this isn't some cologne
sample or cheesy mug Matt great offers
curated gifts collections for every type
of guy from the sport fanatic on down to
the home chef that's who it is
to stay-at-home-dad someone as pathetic
is that I'm kidding obviously
my dream is always to be a stay-at-home
dad
man crates by the way with s I don't
want any confusion about that it's man
crates big capitalists you need to
capitalize this know you know you know
it doesn't matter actually check out
classic crates like the NFL bar where
crate and the whiskey appreciation crate
or fresh takes on traditional
Valentine's gifts like the jerky heart
or the salami bouquet okay a salami
bouquet beef jerky works for me
go to man crates calm pickup the perfect
gift then wait for the magic moment
he'll fall head over heels when the gift
arrives and he gets to pry the wooden
crate open include and it includes a
crowbar they have thousands of five-star
reviews and every gift comes with a
complete satisfaction guarantee so
here's the deal go to man crates dot-com
/h three four five percent off they
don't offer discounts anywhere else so
if you want five percent off your man
crates go to man crates dot-com / h3
right
now that's Mia crates calm slash h3
thank you so much - man crates and
audible for supporting us if you want
support show please consider supporting
one of our sponsors
thank you guys so much and now let's get
right back into it
welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
let me ask you this what do you think
about Alexa and Google assist all these
devices that are going into everybody's
homes even these phones and they're
gonna listening yes yeah do you have any
concerns about that or do you just think
that it's a wonderful evolution of
integrating our lives with technology um
yeah a little bit of concern so like and
I know I also know people who are at
different points on that spectrum some
people are like that's super creepy and
not even being like it's like so
obviously listening to you that like why
would you even bring that in your home
and there's people like me who are more
on the side of just like well if
Google's gonna know everything about me
anyway then I might as well get
something back for it like some sort of
convenience I think like we kind of had
this discussion in a college class I
took a while ago which was like do you
have any privacy and I think I ended up
writing an essay with essentially that
thesis is like well no we don't but
we'll just get something back from the
companies that do something for it I
didn't definitely Facebook is not subtle
at all yeah so I just pulled up this
tweet that you wrote you you wrote
Google we really value your privacy
Twitter we never collect anything Apple
Wiese we securely encrypt everything on
device Facebook literally gives you an
ad for something you know yeah you want
to break that down yeah I mean you see
these statements that like every event
at Google IO Google's like yes you know
we were we're listening to your voice
and analyzing and recognizing it and
training your assistant to recognize
your voice versus your spouses so that
you can both talk to this thing but we
don't collect that so you're good yeah
so they at least feign some sort of like
you know we're doing the right thing
Twitter same thing you know we know
where you are every time you tweet but
it's all good Apple yeah we we kind of
just you use your fingerprint thousands
of times every week and we know exactly
what it but like it's just on your phone
we never see that information it's all
good damn I never thought about the
fingerprint thing yeah face unlock now
it's just scanning your face casually
every time but Facebook
is just unashamedly always right your
wedding in like the grocery store like
walk home and open facebook and it's
like wanna buy that again online because
we have it like all the time so yeah
that's just kind of a thousand spired
but do you or do you find fault with
that do you think that it's wrong what
Facebook's doing the brazen use of your
privacy to sell you [ __ ] is that the
only reason they use your private
information I mean they
so they it's mostly yeah it's for
advertising so there again it's it's
basically like trading your privacy for
convenience to them the ads are so good
that it's stuff you would want to buy
anyway so we know you so well based on
your behavior on Facebook and all the
things we collect and we own Instagram
and now we know where you shop and where
you like to take pictures and all this
stuff about you we know so much about
you that an advertiser can come in with
something they want to buy and find you
because I know you want to buy it so
you're kind of trading like them knowing
everything about you for like the ads
not sucking if it was the other way
around we don't know that much about you
we kind of try not to get in your
privacy here's an ad for diapers do you
care about that like we'd be like all
these as or such trash so on one hand
it's kind of nice that like okay at
least it's advertising something I may
actually buy but on the other hand it's
like kind of creepy that they know so
much and always will
yeah you can't take it back do you hate
any of these listed social medias or
brands tech companies more than other
ones mm-hmm I don't hate them I don't
really use Facebook I hate Facebook I
mean they hate it I hate it you avoid it
I think Facebook is a breeding it's like
everything that's wrong from from the
tops of the bomb how is it rampant
copyright infringement that Facebook
doesn't face but some users know well
the company has has almost no polish
they have a policy but it's not for none
they basically thrive on stealing other
people's content and at least YouTube
has has gotten to the place where
they're making a goodwill effort to
control these things but Facebook is
just the shittiest people the shittiest
company the shittiest interface what do
you think about Mark Zuckerberg like
purses suck yeah you can't cut music I
guess Facebook is
kind of in that place where like it's
ubiquitous everyone knows about Facebook
so he's a robot he's a he's not human
he's an interesting character I don't
know that I don't know anything about it
like Spock like I almost a sweater I
think I would like to not know much
about him I like not knowing about him
because like you see like he's what the
youngest billionaire ever liked the
sweatshirt and billionaire guy walks
around the office with a laptop probably
with a socks on but like what like I
feel like they're so nefarious all the
execs at Facebook I feel like there got
to be a little bit evil or maybe not
evil but cold have you seen the movie
about it what's it called the social
network actually I hadn't but I've heard
very good things I watched it on a plane
like I do with all the movies i watch em
and it's pretty good and it gives a
somewhat accurate and verifiable
backstory to like how the the network
came to be in the people in power there
but yeah just the whole just the
position they're in is is kind of sketch
they can do so much right and we assume
they don't kind of like the NSA in a
weird way Facebook is a weird alternate
NSA they have like as much if it's a
voluntary NSA yeah that's the that's how
they get yeah but for me personally as
time goes on I use Facebook less and I
assume because it becomes less relevant
for my life I don't like it I don't like
what I see there but I assume that other
people would be experiencing the same
thing but yet there's still so many
people using Facebook yeah I yeah I
think but you know what that how they
get you I love Instagram so I come out
one end and I enter another yeah they
still that is I do that was the smartest
thing they've done in a while because
all these young people who never even
signed up they think they think see
Facebook the same ways say like MySpace
like it's all old people should nobody's
on there anymore but Instagram all
everyone all the kids are on Instagram
yep
so Facebook is all right you know what
will swoop down and we'll get all of
those people's information to just
owning it oh yeah they're smart to their
credit they haven't [ __ ] with
Instagram that much Instagram stole
pilots its own ship which I like I like
seeing companies like like obviously I
don't like seeing faces by Instagram but
I like when they buy it but it also let
them run
chips though that's cool but yet they're
they're kind of just doing their thing
now so based on what you said about you
only watch movies on airplanes yeah and
I've heard you say that you almost never
watched anything when your Netflix do
you not watch stuff is that I watched a
lot of YouTube
god bless that's about as much as I will
who do you like really do watch a lot of
YouTube well yeah I if the percentage of
the pie of like media I consume it's a
huge percentage of the pie
I don't like watch hours and hours and
hours of YouTube but like that's well
get your entertain that's where I get my
entertainment so there's a like even
like TV stuff like SportsCenter you
could you could you know claim the only
reason I really watched TV is for sports
mm-hmm but when I can get those
highlights or that calm ROI on YouTube
later it's like the only place I need to
go for for stuff there's youtubers i
watch there's companies i watch that
upload to youtube the whole thing is all
there i think people underestimate how
incredible youtube is because there's
youtubers we all kind of live in our own
bubble and we all [ __ ] and moan about
all the little annoying things big
annoying things but it's all frickin
powerful it's so well biggest platform
there is it's not sanic and like I mean
it's gotta be and people are always
talking about like oh there's gonna be a
new competitor because YouTube keeps
[ __ ] up I don't think people
understand how impossible it is to get
where they are now all the [ __ ] did
they've been through all the [ __ ]
they've got all the lawsuits the
learning how to run a web so they have
decades of experience nobody else even
has any yeah I was I had a meeting a
super long time ago where I heard
somebody at YouTube I remember who say
because of the scale of YouTube they've
had every single problem every single
exactly interesting problem that that
you could that you could possibly have
it it becomes multiplied cuz even if you
know the billions and billions of things
that are on YouTube if the most crazy
tiny obscure thing is that thousandth of
a percent that's like 500 people yeah
like that are having that little tiny
problem and they're gonna be vocal about
it so like they've gone through at all
another one it's like every country
every even state has their own laws and
somehow YouTube has to abide by every
Engels person it's so interesting that
vid me shut down they were like well
they seemed like they would get
somewhere with time you know they were
like that was the closest anyone got and
they just straight-up shut down like
they had a name recognition during that
pocalypse everyone was talking about vid
me they're just like [ __ ] it we tried
yeah yeah yeah I wanna ask you who what
is your favorite tech company um is
Tesla cheating no no vessel the tech
company right yeah I would say Tesla's
up there Google is pretty close behind
just because of the the stuff they don't
software recently with Google assistant
and the camera and the pixel mmm really
good stuff
Google assist yeah incredibly helpful it
is surprising they're like okay yep and
and I love how you squeeze it yeah I got
oh I gotta lower my sensitivity because
like I get on my pocket I squeeze it
already but like yeah just asking it
like what's the weather in this place
are how what's the traffic to work or
how's my restaurant show me a good
restaurants nearby grace the traffic to
Ethan's studio did you ask it that I
should have I know that within tech
reviewing culture the genre on YouTube
or or in general there's always a fine
line for you guys to skirt where you
want to be in the good favor of a
company like Samsung or whoever or even
Google so you're always confronted with
this issue of like what can I say I
don't know if you do it but I'm just
asking do I slam this product that I
hate and lose favor of them because that
that's got to be something that enters
every tech reviewer mine is that
something that you think about or that
you're aware of in the in the culture
yeah yeah that's been um like a hot
button especially in the last like two
years I would say we're you know
youtubers weren't part of press for the
longest time so we'd never had this
issue right you buy the phone you review
it based on whether you like what you
bought or not but at this point it's
gotten to you know
YouTube's pretty sizable and there's
these people who have it enough of an
influence where if they review your
product
I would say you have more influence than
anyone else like as much as anyone on
the planet when it comes to so now now
that you now that companies see that
they're treating youtubers at that level
like press so they'll send you their
product and you review it I think a lot
of people who are starting early even
early exactly and that how valuable is
it to you and other viewers to get a
product early it's massive for for
especially the the first couple like
hours and days of something being
available everyone who is considering
buying it has that small pool of content
to choose to watch to decide to buy it
or not so it's very powerful content as
well so yeah so now so now they're
sending us these products and if you
find something you don't like about it I
think a lot of people their instinct
when they're not in this position is
probably oh I don't want to say too many
bad things because they won't send it to
me next time or they won't send it to me
early I don't find that to be a problem
with what I'm doing I've gotten people
accused that all the time like oh you're
you're not harsh enough on the iPhone or
you're not saying all the bad things you
don't like there's a couple phones I've
reviewed in the last year that I've
ruined like absolutely ruined and will
probably I mean I don't know if I
directly affect sales or if I can
measure that in any way but there's
phones that are just not good and then
I'll say they're not good and you need
to know it's not good so you don't buy
it mhm so but the ones the the initial
impressions videos I give a little more
leeway with everyone just because I just
picked up the phone for the first time
there are things that can be fixed with
software updates you know there's all
those types of things so I'm trying to
understand where they came from when
they put this product together that's in
my hand right now but um I really don't
find myself swayed by access or or them
sending me for free at this point you
find that the companies are like if you
give Samsung just a random example yeah
a bad review do you find in general them
or any other company will distance
themselves from you if you slam them or
they're not all pretty gracious I've
been pretty happy with the way they
responded to it so a lot of times
they'll send a device early and I'll
give them some feedback and part
that is of course negative there are
things I don't like and they'll usually
give them feedback you me privately or
in a video both a lot of times it's just
in the video they watch the video and
then they email me hey we saw what you
didn't like and they'll wonder how they
can follow up or make that better
interesting uh a couple years ago I
really tore down a Motorola camera and
one of their phones it was a great phone
I loved it
this was great that was great this is
great but the camera is just garbage and
I worked with them directly after my
video when it reached out like if the
camera is really garbage like send us
your photos like send us the shooting
conditions and we'll try to work on and
make them better they push software
updates after the fact
it got better it didn't get great well I
could cut better they tried they had the
best intention in mine so I think these
company is looking at really actually
honest feedback because if you get
negative feedback on a phone you could
either say oh they're just trying to
slander it or whatever or they really
didn't like that about it and you can
try to make it that's valuable feedback
yeah so it's actual feedback that your
if you trust me as a reviewer which is
why I'm assuming you're sending it to me
you're gonna get that same feedback from
people who buy the phone later
interesting so if you get that first
feedback from me before it comes out
that's actually valuable to them so I
feel like they've been pretty good about
not dissing so not distancing themselves
from negative feedback and actually
embracing it which is good I make sense
there's got to be so much money now do
you see you see these big companies that
almost like lobbyists to you guys do you
have you experience like insanely
extravagant parties or invitations or
trips like short of just straight-up
paying you for a good review right they
probably skirt as close as possible to
bribe being your best friend ever yeah
it's a bribe or essentially like have
you experienced that yeah and I avoid it
because it's I get it because they're
trying to make a good impression and
trying to be on your good side as a
reviewer so but like that still won't
change what I like or don't like about
your phone yeah so like me going to that
a nice event in your hotel suite in Soho
you know it doesn't make your phone
better it's like right like let's say
that it's it's manipulation it's like
hey yeah
maybe you maybe you'll be a little
easier on us because we're but we're
friends yeah
yeah yeah I'm know that's what lobbying
is you know I can say I am pretty good
friends with a couple of my contacts at
Apple at Tesla at Google great people
I've hung out with them sure and if
their product next year is trash I'm
gonna call it operational and they know
it and that's not a problem for any of
them have you do or maybe you don't have
to answer it but do you recall anything
like extravagant maybe that you didn't
even attend but you were invited to I
mean there's there's always parties like
at CES half of it is like the show floor
where you go out and you see the
products and everything like that and
then the other half is like the brand's
all trying to court you to come to our
suite or come to the hashtag whatever
hashtag LG party like come to this party
and hang out with us and oh by the way
there's TVs everywhere but it's cool
stuff like that so I don't I'm not a big
party person so I don't even go to that
but I just see it and I understand it
yeah but I don't think it would sway me
that much sure
do you actually ever buy tech or do you
get so much that you do you even have
the need to buy gadgets for tech anymore
I still you must get a lot of free [ __ ]
too
I do but I'm really picky hmm so I like
this one I bought I got a pixel two from
them to review I got the black one I set
out the white one so I bought the white
one so I'm really picky about the stuff
that I use personally everything that I
carry and that's with me I bought hmm
but if you go to the studio yeah there's
tons of stuff there that just showed up
that I'll try to use try and get to it
and when I do I try to treat it as if
I'm unwrapping it like I bought it for
the first time but it's kind of hard
yeah but so starting up you had to buy
everything everything oh yeah yeah I
remember you were one of the first
challenge I was watching way back before
I even had a channel and you had like
these great cameras and [ __ ] I can't
even imagine being able to like you had
all the coolest [ __ ] back yeah yeah I
mean I got picky about like what I want
to actually use obviously and that's
what drives my decision of like
reviewing things in the first place but
yeah in the beginning it was like I got
my laptop bought it reviewed it and I'm
like alright what's the next video I
bought a laptop cool
I'm gonna review that now like it's one
thing at a time based on what I am
buying that philosophy still stays with
me when I'm reviewing stuff now if I had
bought it how would I feel but uh yeah
have you do you believe that you should
be able to edit tweets I strongly
believe that you should be able added
tweets I know that you talk about it
it's 28 man but because in a way you
need the historical here's the case you
need you need history preserved right
and the likely targets by the way
archives all of the president's tweets
also man archiving is real but here's
the thanks so like you can edit Facebook
posts you can edit Instagram everything
short of the actual internet special
though it's different Witter is not
sacred
it is not so this is so annoying
well usually when you have a typo you're
like I [ __ ] up and then you
immediately erase it but like if you
tweet out something really embarrassing
mm-hmm and then like three hours later
everyone's [ __ ] on you and you want
to change it I'm sure you think that'd
be funnier you can go yeah I think I
think you should be able to do you
should be able to edit your tweet within
a certain time frame you caught the type
of I'm a little bit that's Twitter show
the Edit history put a little asterisk
next to it that's it that's all I asked
then a typo sometimes I'm like literally
like people ask me if I make typos on
purpose I complain I don't I read my own
tweet like six times in the compose
window for your I don't catch the typo I
tweet it bro and then so on a rope I
like I bet you wish you could edit
tweets I'm like what are you talking and
just pointed out the COFF COFF fifi we
got to pull a trump sometimes and just
defend our typos you're right yeah to
the death is there any tech you want but
can't afford
there's all kinds of cars I want the
Roadster
the roadsters brand-new two million
dollar Bugatti vighati about it I
watched a video daddy there's a youtuber
i watch who just has like a car
collection who just does videos about
his cars and every time i watch one of
those videos i'm like i kind of want
that car now
like he reviews it very sincerely like
this is the Rolls Royce I use to get
groceries because and I think that goes
into the details about the trunk space
now quiet it is and how much Headroom he
has while he's getting all these things
it's not quite the same I'm in this
world of like pocketable technology
where it's usually pretty attainable
relatively attainable yeah we have got a
question from Zak all right Zak what the
[ __ ] is up my doggy
hey guys oh hey well how's it going hey
good you got a you got a question for
our so just yeah just wanted to get you
guys opinion on planned obsolescence in
the tech industry and whether you see
that as a huge issue or if it's more of
a necessary evil especially in regards
to the battery slowing down stuff with
apple also marques chat wants to know
what the K is for in first call it all
right don't
I've actually fans I appreciate your gut
blushes okay the K is my middle initial
in case obvious anyone was wondering so
that's what that is but so yeah I did
you hear about the the iPhone yes and
the battery diversity and all that for
anyone who hasn't I guess to make it
super simple like Apple smartly realizes
that the iPhones battery isn't perfect
and doesn't last forever as batteries do
they age so it can't maintain the same
massive changes in voltages as when it
was a brand new phone as when it's two
years old so when Apple sees a an iPhone
get a software update and they see oh it
has a two-year old battery
they underclock the processor they slow
it down a bit so that the battery can
keep up and doesn't degrade too fast
smart right what they didn't tell anyone
was any of that so now someone has to do
a benchmark and find Oh Apple
under clocks the CPUs of old phones
period that seems like a bad thing to do
like oh you're slowing it down and when
someone's iphone slows down what do they
think I need a new phone right sure
don't think I need a new battery yeah
but if you replace the battery of an old
iPhone but can use like new so you could
pay Apple for it and they would replace
your battery or you could you could get
a third party to do it for however many
dollars but basically when everyone
found out and they were super angry
about the fact that all you needed was a
new battery they lowered the amount they
charged for a battery upgrade from 79 to
$29 something like that feel still got
mad about charging for it but like let's
be real 20 new your phone the lesson is
communication just like with you well
they were clearly capitalizing on that
misunderstanding for many years
definitely they could have easily you
know they were enjoying people buying
new phones I would never doubt that
there was conversations at Apple where
they were like well you know we'll do
you know battery they go through the
whole thing and they're like well people
are gonna buy new iPhones when their
phone slows down right yeah they are but
if they want a battery upgrade yeah
that's cool too
yeah I would charge for that too but
there was a really good analogy by one
of my friends Quinn who's a youtuber who
mentioned like you wouldn't get mad at
like Acura for not replacing your tires
like tires where they get old and after
a while your car starts to skid and you
can't really take turns the same way and
it's like man I think I need a new car
but people don't understand the entirety
of how cars work and all they need is
new tires should they replace your tires
for free no they'll still charge for it
but I guess the difference being that
that's a more intuitive difference you
can see why your tires are balding and
that's why your skidding out worth I did
a good analogy but I think people don't
get how iPhones work yeah and yeah and
it's not really intuitive and they
didn't really take the initiative to
educate anyone because they were
enjoying everybody buying new phones
every year so apparently they're gonna
they're gonna push a software update
that lets you pick that's gracious
that's cool that is very cool something
I would have expected Apple to ever do
but they'll let you pick they gotten a
lot of [ __ ] for that crush my sheep it's
all good so basically old phones were
faced with the choice of either your
battery life
we'll be trash will be trash or your
kimono pelvic mostly nose now you'll
have a button did you choose that would
you take I would take I would pick
changing my battery power D bucks I
would yeah exactly I would say keep
crushing my battery and eventually when
it dies all get a new one yeah I think I
do I think there was definitely internal
conversations and also the conclusion to
be like and let's not tell anyone about
this because we're making a fuckload of
money from it yeah
and now whatever money they made they've
made it and now another my Netflix and
Tesla all right
one last question for you sure this is
customary we ask you to well very guess
it's a little strange okay feel free to
say no if it doesn't apply to you that's
okay we get that all the time do you
have any ghost stories or paranormal
experiences UFO alien visitations
anything strange or paranormal has it
ever happened to you Wow um I don't
think I can think of any like I i've
watched those shows where i like think
about it I actually have a hilarious
story about my childhood which is
nothing very little to do with this okay
I'll take first time okay yeah so I was
a really little kid
we watched ET which is you know if
you've watched ET it's so pretty
weird-looking alien like so we watch it
I'm probably like eight or nine or
something my sister can vouch for this
like after Oh backstory to the backstory
in my bedroom in my house we have these
closets with these automatically turning
on lights motion sensors so if you open
the the closet door it sees a motion it
opens turns on the light so that's cool
so after we watched the movie ET I go up
to my room to go to sleep trying to go
to sleep
closet door is open I'm thinking about
aliens boom closet light turns on for no
reason I freaked out I lose it I'm like
beauties in my closet I don't know what
to do where do I go I scream my parents
like what am i ET is my closet ET wasn't
in my closet it was just a paranormal
light turning on for no reason but from
that
I really don't like et I've heard that a
lot 80s car it's hardly enough for kids
it's kind of a weird is if you look at
pictures of it like it's a weird dude is
that enough just to get I feel like
enough times password if I type et maybe
something else comes up et seen know and
like the this is bro you wake up faced
with that this is another nice looking
face like 10 years ago the movie was
like this like clay caricature so it was
like you could see like texture in it
and like wrinkles wonder why they made
him so so odd yeah man they just think
of a [ __ ] Steven Spielberg right it's 20
looks like a cigar okay yeah it look
like that huh
but oh my god imagine this peeking out
from the dark exactly Majan the closet
light turning off alright thanks for
sharing that yeah and more than that
thank you for coming I know you had a
really busy tight schedule I really
appreciate you making the time to come
spend the day with us or they have the
evening looks great appreciate it
your time it was a lot of fun this is
real yeah I appreciate you god bless ya
guys everybody thanks to you for
watching next week we are having the
great and wonderful Jordan Peterson back
on the podcast for a second visit very
much looking forward to that that's an
unusual day right damn what is it yeah
yeah that's gonna be on a Thursday next
week I'm gonna post on the subreddit
right now Oh what time
- I think yet - how are you normally at
three but an hourly yeah so please tune
in for that until then I hope you all
have a great weekend and a great week
and I hope that you are not having heat
seen your closet mm-hmm going safe
comfortable at home and we wish you all
the best I'll see you guys next time
see you next